how's it going bros money's paid path
welcome to yandere simulator the
greatest empire simulator that has ever
simulated since 2004 at least so are we
up a bit a bit pepper dip it Bo let's
select our panties oh my god how do I
not I'm gonna have to call I'm it's
pissing me off how I don't know what
they're called yeah my core and what it
what are the what is a beer call that
you always like the beard the beer
Rilakkuma
Rilakkuma there we go okay that's all I
want thank you okay right Rilakkuma
that's what the beer is called yes well
let's go to school today is a new day
today's temp is gonna notice me I can
feel it just follow this road I'm sure
we'll get there eventually this is the I
want this song to play on my funeral
it's so good
and they lower my casket down just play
the song so good really speaks to me
hey so now what we need to do brows is
gonna be amazing
we need the screwdriver hey you all my
my love MA
there's only you in my life I hate her
I hate you just cuz you have bigger tits
doesn't mean you're better than me look
I have big tits too [ __ ] alright so at
7:30 something ish she's gonna come in
here mmm mmm Metta Bam Bam but Abed
where is she
oh my god what is she where where is she
wear panties
oh god I'm stressing the panties up the
[ __ ] out Jesus [ __ ] panties is she in
the bathroom okay alright alright
unscrew and then turn up no no no don't
go ahead don't go ahead don't go out she
can't go out she can't go out she can't
go out not yet fill the bucket and then
let's empty it on the [ __ ] dammit
dammit god [ __ ] damn it no no I don't
accept this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh no she's
gonna go to the bathroom soon and I'll
be ready
a chest all right where is that the
[ __ ] [ __ ] fill the bucket we gonna
splash you [ __ ] where is she where the
[ __ ] is she no no no no no no no no no
no no where is she where where the
weather is she
weather is she weather I can't I can't I
can't
where is she what is she where is she I
don't know what to say I'm not gonna
wear my lucky panties anymore and that's
a big thing for me all right
like I I would have just let anyone not
make me wear my favorite underwear I
never understand the purpose of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] standing right [ __ ]
there she thinks she's so [ __ ] good
with her smile yeah no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no how do we oh I can
reset a day oh my god
oh god I forgot the [ __ ] screwdriver
a [ __ ] n-no no runyan they're a child
ah
young young young panties
where the [ __ ] you should go in or the
[ __ ] are you going okay this is gonna be
amazing
it's gonna be like we worked so it's
filled with blood what the [ __ ] is
glitch let's fill with blood let's let's
[ __ ] shame this [ __ ] for having nice
tits
alright let's do it yeah yes it is [ __ ]
oh the [ __ ] is she doing what is that
you're not a werewolf where's she going
what is this let's get naked
yeah just gonna make it with this [ __ ]
yes all right
yeah that's right babban a bit bad but a
bit oh she's struggling let's kill her
while she's naked take some nudes this
will go up on 4chan let's make sure it
doesn't fill with [ __ ] blood this
time thank you my god that's not [ __ ]
you just got me all right so now she's
this should work this should work the
should work I have to turn the stupid
lights back on where is it
yes hahaha stay toasty oh look at her
she's so dead my god
this is the best thing that has ever
happened to me okay Bruce that was it
for this episode think it was so much
for watching remember to check out
yandere dev follow his stuff it's
amazing I love this game so much thank
you for like this video I really
appreciate it and as always I'll see you
breasts in the next video stay awesome
French whoa I'm in here now I can watch
see why I say it's my favorite game
because I can change my underpants
I'm going for the striped ones cos the
stripes shows up the curls up there
girl's butt